in dieser sendung wieder immer
deutschland kritisiert mit wie drehen da
die politiker durch den fleischwolf wir
wissen alles besser wissen der liebe
gott weiß alles wie es noch etwas besser
und damit immer fürchterlich kritisiert
und deutschland kommt oftmals schlecht
weg vor allem das politische deshalb
habe ich hier ein thema nachdem sich
alle deutschen besser fühlen können denn
es gibt eben auch in anderen ländern
fürchterlich durchgeknallte menschen zum
beispiel in der schweiz und dort findet
sie brachte der normalverteilung auch in
der politik und dieser durchgeknallten
haben in der schweiz jetzt ein neues
gesetz verabschiedet das in unserer
demokratie auch angenommen werden wird
ein neues ehegesetz und in diesem gesetz
wird der vater gestrichen also die
schweiz schafft den vater ob wir haben
eine partnerschaft ein ehegesetz in dem
das wort vater nicht mehr voll kommt
wohl aber mutter das wort vater wird
aber setzt durch elternteil und jetzt
kommt durch samenspende und das ist
nehme das nehme ich persönlich das ist
ein unglaublicher affront ich bin
vierfacher vater ich werde jetzt von
diesem feministischen wahnsinn alsmann
zurückgestuft vom vater zum samenspender
zu einer art nutzt hierzu einem
zertifizierten sucht die den
samenständen dürfen nur die das vorher
bei den behörden angemeldet haben ich
finde das ist fürchterlich aber bevor
ihr zu füßen lacht hier ich sage euch
das kommt nach deutschland denn ihr habt
hier schon politiker in reutlingen da
kandidiert ein mann für die grünen als
frau und dann haben sie gefragt wieso
konzentrieren sie als frauen für ein
politisches amt sagte er weiß im
einklang mit unserem parteiprogramm ist
das geschlecht ist eine persönliche
entscheidung außer der wahnsinn pflanzt
sich schneller folgt aus dass carola
virus hier seid nicht sicher deutsche
männer wehret den anfängen
also den vater ausradieren das wirklich
froh dass die schweizer zuerst gemacht
haben denn ich glaube du hast recht
geben da setzt ja quasi eine eine kette
von erstaunlicher also annalena baerbock
wenn ich das richtig in einem wir ja
auch gesetzestexte
gender ländern also das heißt
geschlechtsneutral formulieren
das ist eine wir sind glaube ich auf
einem weg der selbstvergessenheit in
einen in einen absurden
zustand des keiner weiß mehr wer er
wirklich ist denn vielleicht hält sich
dann irgendwann ein vater auch selber
nicht wo ich sagen wir einmal glücklich
gewesen über das gesetz boris becker
wäre vermutlich das ist einfach alles
sagen und werden dadurch die löwen
fallen dadurch gingen aber ist es auch
wir beschäftigen uns inzwischen in
unseren politischen extrem elitären
babbels mit themen die alle nur noch auf
eine sache hinweisen wir kennen keine
probleme mehr nur gesellschaften die
wirklich über jahrzehnte frei von armut
wenn ich höre wie waben deutschland
angebliches gerade in dem wahlkampf dass
es überall armut herrscht wenn wir uns
mit diesen themen die ganze zeit
beschäftigen welche gesetzestext wie
geändert werden soll
ob man noch schwarzfahrer sagen darf ja
oder nein das kann ja nur darauf
hindeuten und das ist eine gute
nachricht dass wir seit jahrzehnten
überhaupt gar keine ernsthaften probleme
mehr kennen aber das drückt ist wir
haben sie jetzt was also wir haben ja
pandemie wir haben ja grosse unwetter
und ihre milliarden folgen wir haben ja
eine instabile internationale situation
wir haben mir eine ausbreitung des
islamismus wir haben ja ein
integrationsproblem von menschen die zu
uns gekommen sind also wir haben ja jede
menge probleme vielleicht ist das so
eine ersatzhandlung um sich mit den
wirklichen problemen
das wäre aber ganz gefährlich weil das
ist nämlich wie ein autofahrer der zwar
seine bremse
nicht die nicht funktioniert das ist
aber immer schneller genauer schwierig
wird das ist die realitätsflucht in den
wahnsinn den man für die wirklichkeit
hält und das ist genau die erfindung von
irgendwelchen scheint probleme man
steigert sich in etwas hinein und genau
wie du sagst nicht über die eigentlichen
wirklichkeiten zu stellen natürlich der
muskel denn vertreter diskussion
realitätsflucht eine wirklich so sagen
eine pervertierte form der romantik ich
bin nicht gegen romantik aber romantik
die dann in den wahnsinn sich davon
träumt dann sind wir bei der abschaffung
des vaters da sind wir bei der
abschaffung der wirklichkeit und das
sage ich jede wetten dass sendung mit
thomas gottschalk hatte mehr faktizität
mehr wirklichkeit gehalt mehr
realitätsgehalt als die politik die
heute gemacht wird stehen sollten der
schluss war stehen lassen
die schweizer
überstehen doch ja ich bin da auch der
mann natürlich habe ich oft auch
darunter gelitten dass ich um 20 uhr 15
die tagesschau gesehen hatte oder die
tagesthemen oder was auch immer und dann
einmarschiert bin und gesagt haben und
hier kommt einer der eine kuckucksuhr
blind mit in drei minuten zusammenbaut
haben wie man hat die welt keine anderen
probleme ja sie hatte sie aber wenn der
showmaster schon darunter leidet dass er
die show in den vordergrund sein ist
seines wesens und seine science stellt
und nicht die wirklichkeiten jetzt bin
gottseidank politik folgte auf dem fuße
heute ist er im entertainment ist mehr
realität also in der politik aber das
ist natürlich auch das versagen diese
journalisten hier am tisch die bringen
es offensichtlich nicht fertig diese
politiker so zu steuern dass sie sich
mit der wirklichkeit auseinandersetzen
die müssten mehr fernsehen schaue und
beweglichkeit zu entdecken für mich
übrigens das schönste dieser
nischenthemen gerade hochgekommen letzte
anekdote ein junger mann der gesagt hat
ich habe meine sexualität entdeckt meine
sexuelle orientierung ich nenne mich
super straight super straight heißt ich
stehe auf frauen die immer frauen waren
als frauen geboren wurden er ist und
sich selber als frauen empfinden sprich
einfach ganz normal ich stehe auf frauen
er ist für dieses video auf diversen
social media plattform gesperrt
weil es als
feindselig gegenüber menschen gegolten
hat die sich dort nicht so wirklich
zuordnen können meine liebste anekdote
aus dem wok wahnsinn der letzten der
vergangenen der vergangenen wochen und
da gehört das ja auch also so ein
bisschen nämlich sage da ist es also die
schweiz schlechter dran da können sich
die deutschen noch zurücklehnen leicht
amüsiert und sagen es gibt doch noch
ländern in denen es verrückter läuft als
bei uns zumindest in diesem bereich das
haben wir uns oft immer gesagt haben ich
noch gerne auf die schweiz gewohnt und
gesagt bei den schweizern ist es noch
ein bisschen verrückter
[Musik]